السباق نحو كرسي الرئاسه في تركيا يشتد في
ظل استقطاب حاد قبيل ايام من التوجه الى
صناديق الاقتراع كل مرشح يحاول رمي اوراقه
لاقناع الناخبين بالتصويت له المنافسه تهم
بالاساس الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ومرشح حزب
الشعب الجمهوري كما الكليتش دار اوغلو
مرشح المعارضه الذي يقدم نفسه باسم كمال
تيمنا بكمال اتاتورك رفع السقف عاليا وقدم
وعودا لارضاء الاتراك ابرز هذه الوعود
دخولهم الى الاتحاد الاوروبي دون تاشيره
وضمان استئناف المفاوضات بشان انضمام
تركيا الى بروكسل والحصول على استثمارات
بقيمه 300 مليار دولار بالاضافه الى اعاده
اللاجئين السوريين والافغان الى بلدانهم
الاصليه في غضون عامين كحد اقصى من بين
خطط قصيره المدى اذا ما وصل الى السلطه
ضمان استمرار صفقه الحبوب وانهاء الصراع
في اوكرانيا وال الاتفاقيه مونترو فضلا عن
محاربه الارهاب وربط علاقات اوثق مع
الناتو
تعهد ايضا باعاده تركيا الى النظام
البرلماني وضمان استقلال المحاكم وتعزيز
الحريه الصحفيه
في المقابل وصفه اردوغان للاحتفاظ بكرسي
الرئاسه لم تختلف كثيرا عن الانتخابات
السابقه الرئيس الحالي قدم وعودا بجعل
تركيا قويه ومتعدده التحالفات وخلق سته
ملايين وظيفه وتحقيق معدلات نمو عاليه مع
اعطاء دفعه كبيره للسياحه والدفاع عن قيام
الاسره ورفض فكره اعاده اللاجئين خاصه
السوريين الى بلادهم بالقوه
اردوغان تعهد ايضا بجعل تركيا اكثر حريه
وامانا وازدهارا لجميع مواطنيها وبناء قرن
تركيا وهو برنامج يتضمن اهدافا في المئويه
الجديده بدعم من الاكراد بلال البجديني
العربي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات